[Music]
i know saturn cloud is a fairly young
company
but has already made a name for itself
contributing to
the pi data community after all you're
one of our sponsors for pi data global
what motivates saturn cloud to be
a contributor to the community in this
way from the very birth of the company
yeah so from the beginning we have
always been
full on open source pi data community
it's really
part of our business success our entire
goal is to ensure that data scientists
and data science teams
can successfully use the pi data
ecosystem scale
their code with desks so we wanted to
make sure
that we were contributing from the
beginning because we're relying
and we're relying on top of these
awesome packages we want to make sure
that we can continue to contribute to
them
by actually adding code to them
contributing to events and pushing
forward
the community because this is really
honestly it's central to our business
erin pydata global is not the first pi
data conference that you've attended
outside of just the software pi data to
a lot of people means a community of
like-minded users
what interests you or excites you or
engages you most about the pi data
community
pi data has been an awesome community
for me my my first exposure to it was
through the pi data miami group that's
actually relatively new and i was able
to help
kind of build that up be part of the
organizing efforts
and do a conference here but i would say
that this part of the community
probably is the the biggest community
thing that
even gave me my job at saturn i wouldn't
have known about saturn cloud but i
actually met saturn cloud
through pi data before i even started
working there so
for me personally it's been a great
avenue for my own career growth
i've been able to meet awesome people
that even people who have
created big open source packages and
these kind of
more celebrity names that you would hear
and see on twitter or
kind of see contributing to packages and
like wow you know those people are
really smart and doing awesome things
i'm able to either sit in the same room
with them meet them talk to them see
them at different conferences
virtually currently um but i think the
pi day community has been really great
for this entire ecosystem of tools but
even just as a data scientist trying to
kind of progress my career meet people
network
it's it's been an awesome community
[Music]
you